well we begin now with some breaking
news from Scotland where the former
first Minister Nicholas sturgeon has
been arrested it appears to be in
connection with an investigation into
the Scottish national party's funding
and finances well let's go straight to
Rory challenge he joins us live from
London Rory I understand police raided
Nicholas durden's home back in April and
arrested her husband too but he was
released
yes that's right um so there have been
three people arrested so far in what the
Scottish police are calling Operation
Branch form this is as you say this
investigation into allegations of sort
of financial uh impropriety at the
Scottish national party essentially what
they're looking into is whether 750
000 pounds worth of donations to an
independence campaign were mispensed by
the party now those three people that
have been arrested Peter Murrell who is
Nicholas sturgeon's husband and the
former chief executive of the party uh
an fmsp a member of the Scottish
Parliament uh called Colin Beatty and
now Nicola sturgeon herself who resigned
stepped down as the leader of the party
back in April for for various reasons
um but this is now escalating into into
a pretty serious issue for one of the
titans of Scottish politics Rory given
all that's happened how's the SNP
regarded by the public now
well they're in trouble at the moment uh
it's perhaps not terminal trouble
considering how much of a dominant
position they have had in Scotland over
the last few years in no small reason
due to Nicolas sturgeon herself she as I
said just now it is a Titan was a Titan
of Scottish politics very very dominant
and it could largely do what she pleased
politically for for many many years but
when she stepped down in April that
decision was seen as a recognition on
her part that she was kind of losing her
touch to a certain degree that her
strategy for achieving Scottish
independence which obviously she'd never
achieved in three years of trying was it
odds with other other important people
in her party and also perhaps that she
was now out of favor with the Scottish
public the particularly there were
issues to do with the Scottish gender
recognition Bill a bill that she had
kind of pushed through that made it
easier for people in Scotland to legally
change their sex or gender that was not
particularly popular with the
electorates at large but of course
bubbling behind all of that were these
growing concerns about the party's
finances and how they spent them that
has now come to the fore and Hamza Yusuf
who is the new leader of the Scottish
national party has a very tricky issue
on his hands we're going to get a
general election in the country next
year and there are certainly feelings
amongst the labor party in the UK that
they might have an opportunity now to
really get back some of their lost
ground in Scotland and deal the SMP a
serious blow but of course that's for
the future the the party has big issues
to deal with at the moment Rory
challenged there across that store story
from us from for us I'm sorry from
London thank you very much Rory